es ist spät wie so oft die kinder müssen
in die schule nokia der dollar
verabschiedet ihre familie alltag und
alptraum zugleich denn sie muss mit
ihrem vierten kind zu hause bleiben wie
seit beginn der pandemie vanessa ihre
älteste leidet an sichelzellenanämie
einer seltenen blutkrankheit siegen
schlaganfälle eine
knochenmarkstransplantation
das schicksal der 17-jährigen hier mit
ihren jüngeren schwestern bestimmt
bookies leben seit corona ein sehr
einsames
wir sind extrem vorsichtig vanessa muss
den ganzen tag drinnen
ein leben hinter verschlossener tür aber
nasa will nicht gefilmt werden sie sei
oft depressiv erzählt bucchi sie hat
ihren job in der beautybranche
aufgegeben zur lebensberaterin
umgeschult kann so von zu hause arbeiten
der mann hat gleich ganz gekündigt alle
bringen große opfer
es ist nicht einfach für die familie zu
jedem und allem nein zu sagen und dann
den kindern sagen warum sie ihre freunde
nicht treffen können uns niemand
besuchen darf wir das nicht tun dürfen
und nein auch nicht ins kino das ist
schwer für alle meine kinder sogar für
mich als erwachsene
wer von draußen kommt muss sich testen
jeder in der familie könnte corona ins
haus bringen bookies größte sorge im
sommer erwischte es die familie trotz
aller vorsicht auch vanessa die nicht
geimpft werden darf
ich sagte ihr sie können die maske
abziehen das machte sie
und ihr dämmerte mama habe ich corona
ich sagte ja
sie wollen nicht sterben sagte sie
fing an zu weinen
zum glück hat vanessa nur milde symptome
entwickelt doch die angst ist geblieben
wie bei so vielen der 1,7 millionen
briten so genannten schildern die der
nationale gesundheitsdienst vergangenes
jahr angewiesen hatte sich in
selbstisolation zu begeben wegen
vorerkrankungen
sie galten als stark gefährdet
seitdem freiheitstag im juli gibt es
keine gesetzlichen chor ohne
einschränkungen mehr wer will gibt in
england vollgas noch mehr als eine
million schilder so das nationale
statistikamt würden sich auch weiter
isolieren oder einschränken
sowie rnv als starker asthmatiker
diabetiker trotz einer landesweiten
inzidenz von fast 400 erklärt die
regierung nun menschen die er hätten
nichts mehr zu befürchten
um es ganz deutlich zu sagen ich bin
wirklich richtig werk
es wirkt als ob die regierung corona für
beendet erklärt hat
keine täglichen auftritte mehr wie die
lage ist
du musst keine maske mehr tragen
der gesunde menschenverstand sagt dir
das ist falsch
du brauchst nicht viel recherchieren das
virus ist weiter da draußen
[Musik]
doppelt gekämpft aber das schütze eben
nicht zu 100 prozent
der riesen bond fan kann den neuen 007
nicht im kino sehen seitdem freiheitstag
hätten viele im beschaulichen keller
jede vorsicht aufgegeben dazu sei die
impfbereitschaft landesweit
eingeschlafen und er der leidtragende so
der 50 jährige
für uns schilder wird es erst wieder
sicher wenn sich noch mehr impfen lassen
heute wieder was getragen
raus für spaziergänge und für die arbeit
wo er ins kollegen ihm zuliebe maske
tragen abstand halten rücksicht nehmen
nicht die stärke des premiers diese
woche besuch in einem krankenhaus masken
los gedankenlos seit wochen erklären die
top mediziner des landes zurück zur
masken pflicht zum home office gebot
mehr vorsicht sonst drohe wieder die
überlastung des gesundheitssystems die
maske nimmt boris johnson dann doch die
warnungen ignoriert
ich nehme das war aber unterschiedliche
wissenschaftler sagen unterschiedliche
dinge
warum es so läuft damit es hier wieder
läuft das bier von german kraft zwei
junge deutsche design studenten machen
2017 aus ihrer leidenschaft ein geschäft
mittlerweile sind es drei brauerei
standorte in london 110 angestellte
corona trieb sie an den rand des ruins
der freiheitstag die kam im letzten
moment
nicht nur uns aber allen anderen
kleinunternehmer im ganzen land ganz
london natürlich ähnlich dass irgendwann
jeder pleite ist und ich meinen dann
kann auch keiner weiterleben aber es
waren gruppen draußen freunde des jahres
soll zudem auch toll zu finden die
ganzen wir unsere ganzen mitarbeiter
zusammen gearbeitet haben und auch
wieder bequem haben
keine westliche wirtschaft wurde von
corona so hart getroffen nicht nur
london lebt staat und den
dienstleistungen die beiden bierbrauer
haben während der lockdown da versucht
ihr frisch gebrautes in kleine fässer zu
füllen überall in der stadt zu verkaufen
wir haben diese fahrt jeden tag gemacht
sieben tage die woche für drei monate um
die fünf liter fässchen um zu fahren und
am ende kam halt so viel umsatz dabei
raus wie bei dem ersten samstag als wir
hier wieder aufgemacht haben haben wir
einen tag so viel umsatz gemacht wie
zweieinhalb drei monate jeden tag rum
fahren durch london
die freiheit um sich wirtschaftlich über
wasser halten zu können für andere eine
die sie ihrer freiheit beraubt wenn ihr
alles zu viel wird flieht nokia den ball
an immer an den nahen strand
hunderttausende schüler und ihre
familien leiden sagt sie der andere ihr
leben uneingeschränkt zurückhaben wollen
[Musik]